katey sagal so much fun yeah that
dynamic like when she's on set well she
has a history of playing Kaylee's mom so
I think there's any way back a little
reunion there and we get to have new
characters to play with she's going to
be a little bit of an erotic character
because she spent her life with her
troubled son Randall who has been in a
jam when has had some issues with
dealing drugs and so we're gonna start
to dig into all that do you ever hear do
you hear this enjoyable I want very fun
I just found out about this casting news
the other day and I was so excited and
Jack McBrayer playing Kenny's brother
it's so easy why don't someone ask you
people are always so worried that
BIGBANG is going away they're like this
could be it is this much more BIGBANG do
you have in the tank we're all having a
good time I think you know the I think
you know it's the cast you know talks
about wanting to keep going and keep
making this and all of you seem to yeah
each other and yeah it's not up to us
but be wonderful
but if it helps our ratings that people
think this is the last season this is it
guys
you heard her today